- [Voiceover] Jacob charges
$9.00 an hour to paint.
The graph below shows the
number of hours he spent
painting different rooms of one house.
How much did Jacob charge
for painting the living room?
So here's the graph, this is a
picture graph, or pictograph,
and it shows us how much
time Jacob spent painting
different rooms of a house.
One super important thing is
this little key right here
that tells us each of these paint buckets
is three hours of time.
We're asked about the living room.
On the graph, we can find
where it says living room
and see how many buckets.
Remember, each of these buckets
equals three hours of time.
He spent three hours,
plus another three hours,
so he spent a total of six
hours painting the living room.
But the question asks us,
how much did Jacob charge.
Jacob charges $9.00 for every hour,
and he worked for six hours,
so he charged $9.00 six times.
$9.00 for each of the six hours he worked,
which is a total
of $54.00.
Jacob charged a total of $54.00
to paint the living room.